the robots of the cartoons and movies
from the 1970s are going to be the
reality of the 2020s and there are two
real drivers behind this first is
mapping belief space historically it's
been really difficult to be able to
instruct robots to do things like
grasping grasping might seem like a
pretty straightforward thing to do but
it's actually very complex
mathematically and algorithmically to be
able to instruct robots how to do that
and so what this mathematical
breakthrough in mapping belief space has
done is it has taken water historically
very complex tasks for robots and made
them easier to do the second thing is
cloud robotics
so if c-3po right now if he walked over
here and interrupted this big think
interview he would say oh my excuse me
you know and get out of the frame and as
he did this there would be a lot of
hardware and software whirring in that
gold gleaming body of his in reality the
c-3po of the 2020s will be a cloud
connected device and so what he would do
if he stumbled into this interview is he
is he would ping the cloud and he would
get instructions from the hive mind that
is there algorithmically and he would
then know to excuse himself to do so in
English and to though then go clunk away
so what does this mean what this means
is that the robots of our youths and of
our imaginations don't have to have
millions of dollars of incredibly
sophisticated hardware and software in
them they can be relatively lightweight
dumb devices so long as they are
connected to the power of the cloud so
what's the significance okay so they're
cheaper so what the big significance
here really goes to labor so let's think
about the difference between humans and
robots and their costs humans don't have
a lot of capex but they have a lot of
effects so the upfront costs costs you
know maybe your employer by
see some business cards maybe he gets
you a computer for work or something
like that not a lot of capex not a lot
of upfront costs but a lot of op ex
every two weeks you want to get paid
right
a lot of salary a lot of op ex robots
come with and diametrically opposed
cause structure it's a lot of capex
you've got to buy the robot 10 n but
then relatively little op X you can work
them 24 hours a day they aren't going to
join a union or get sick they don't
expect a salary and so what's happening
right now is we're seeing new
equilibrium points in terms of the
trade-off between the relative cost of
capex intense op X light robot and a
capex light op x in high labor of humans
I saw this in all places in East Asia in
the football-field-sized factories of
Foxconn the Taiwanese company that makes
all of our smart phones and Terry GU the
CEO of Foxconn who employs nine hundred
and seventy three thousand people has
decided he's not hiring any more humans
he's just buying robots and so I think
that this is this is fascinating stuff
as the robots of the cartoons in movies
become the reality of the 2020s they
aren't going to look like the metallic
out the metallic robots of of the
cartoons and movies they're actually
going to look more human because of
advances in material sciences from
electroactive polymers to to silk skin
to air muscles and other such things so
the robots of the future may actually
look more like terminator than like Star
Wars what's also interesting that's
happening right now is particularly in
Japan and South Korea there are robots
being developed the purpose of which is
actually to do what we normally think of
as the most intimate human tasks to do
things like take care of our aging
grandparents and part of this is flowing
from an economic imperative
in Japan for example Japan has the
world's oldest population and it's only
growing holder and so companies like
Toyota and Honda
yep the ones that make the cars are now
making elder care robots because there
aren't enough young japanese to take
care of the grandparents and so things
that we think of as very intimate and
very human in the future will be
increasingly robotic it's not a surprise
that this is coming out of Asia
interestingly in societies like Japan
where Shinto is the nash is the national
religion in Shinto for example they have
a belief in animism that objects can
have souls and so that's a big
difference than judeo-christian
religions which think of objects as
being a soulless and if you contrast the
culture and mythology of a lot of Asian
societies it's much more embracing of
automation and of robotics as opposed to
Western societies where from Icarus with
his wax wings to Frankenstein and beyond
most of our culture most of our
mythology is rooted in the risks of
giving life to those things that perhaps
we ought not to so I don't think it's a
big surprise that a lot of these
innovations are coming from East Asia